Maura Stocker brach ein Tabu:
Sie zog
aus der Familienwohnung aus.
Die drei kleinen Kinder
blieben beim Vater.
Ich musste diese Situation und
die Reaktionen von aussen aushalten.
Aushalten,
dass ich quasi schuld bin.
Ich war die Täterin,
war trotzdem traurig -
das war ein Verlust.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Psycho- und Paartherapeutin
Felizitas Ambauen
spricht in diesem Film darüber,
wieso das heutige Bild der perfekten
Mutter allen im Weg steht.
Mutter ist
eine moralische Kategorie.
Sich von der Familie wegzubewegen
wird schnell mit Charakterschwäche
assoziiert. Das ist problematisch.
Auch die Mutter von Lianna Müller
verliess die Familie,
als Lianna drei Jahre alt war.
Trotzdem oder gar deswegen
hatte sie eine schöne Kindheit.
Mein Vater konnte mir
Vaterleibe geben,
die genauso wichtig ist
wie Mutterliebe.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Maura Stocker ist 39 Jahre alt
und lebt in der Stadt Zürich.
Sie ist geschieden, single -
und Mutter dreier Kinder.
Damals, nach der Trennung
vor sieben Jahren,
wohnten die Kinder
zu 70 % beim Vater.
Heute leben sie zur Hälfte bei ihr.
Zu Maura Stockers Lebenstraum
gehörten Kinder dazu.
Noch in der KV-Lehre heiratete sie.
Kurz darauf
kam die erste Tochter zur Welt.
Eine zweite Tochter
und ein Junge folgten.
Das Familienleben schien perfekt.
Die Kleinkinderphase
genoss Maura Stocker.
Sie blühte auf in ihrer Mutterrolle.
Gleichzeitig stellte sie hohe
Ansprüche an sich selber als Mutter.
Im Nachhinein sagt sie,
ihre Ansprüche waren zu hoch.
Ich habe mich ziemlich ausgepowert,
als die Kinder klein waren.
Ich habe viel genäht, usw.
Ähm.
Ich war oft musisch mit den Kindern,
dies und das,
da noch Filzpüppchen usw.
Ich habe mich verausgabt,
es war aber schön.
Ich würde es nicht anders machen.
Auch das Kochen liebte ich!
So richtig la mamma.
Die Postur habe ich nicht, aber
sonst wäre ich so la mamma gewesen.
Sie wollte alles perfekt machen.
Mit einem Kinderschuh-Onlineshop
machte sie sich zudem selbstständig.
Ihr damaliger Mann unterstützte sie.
Dass sie bereits seit ihrer Kindheit
an einem ausgeprägten ADHS leidet,
wusste sie damals noch nicht.
Es könnte zur Überlastung
entscheidend beigetragen haben.
Nachts arbeitete ich,
tagsüber hatte ich die Kinder.
Der Haushalt war chaotisch.
Er war dann eine super Hausfrau.
Also, ein Hausmann,
auch neben der Arbeit.
Aber es war wirklich so ... Bämm!
Così.
Gegen aussen sahen wir aus
wie eine tolle Familie.
Wir konnten das auch gut verkörpern.
Von aussen wirkte sie wie eine Frau
und Mutter, die alles im Griff hat.
Sie wurde gar oft gefragt,
wie sie das alles bloss
unter einen Hut bekomme.
Als die Kinde älter wurden,
merkte ich, dass ich müde wurde.
Das Problem war in mir drin,
nicht aussen.
Das Kochen, nett angezogen sein,
und zu Hause ist es so und so
und tolle Kinder und ...
Und eigentlich ...
Es ratterte innerlich.
Ich musste meinen innerlichen Karren
an die Wand fahren.
Ich habe den gar nicht bemerkt.
Nicht gesehen.
Für mich war es so ...
"Ah, Fasnacht.
Du brauchst ein Kleid."
Da nähte ich in der Nacht
ein Feenkleid.
Ich habe es gar nicht gecheckt.
Maura Stocker sagt,
sie habe sich verausgabt,
ihre Grenzen
weder bemerkt noch gewahrt.
Der Tag war in sich gefüllt
mit dies und das.
Mit den Bedürfnissen der
drei Kinder, dann noch mit meinen,
mit dem Geschäft, meinem Mann, der
Familie, Essen, Kochen, Einkaufen.
Aber als sie im Bett waren
und die Ruhe einkehrte,
war ich so ... Ah!
Ja.
Ich war tief erschöpft.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
2015 hatte sie
eine heftige Panikattacke,
kam ins KIZ,
ins Kriseninterventionszentrum.
Die Diagnose:
eine Erschöpfungsdepression.
Später erfuhr sie da auch,
dass sie an einer
Aufmerksamkeitsdefizit- und
Hyperaktivitätsstörung,
kurz ADHS, litt.
Für mich war es
wie die Hölle zu küssen.
Denn in der Panikattacke
wusste ich nicht,
ob das für immer ist.
Ich kam sehr ... in etwas rein.
Ich musste wie
eine neue Sprache lernen.
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
ich hätte die Hölle geküsst
und es gibt ein Leben davor
und ein Jetzt.
Ich war mir bewusst,
dass es eine Hölle gibt.
"Komme ich hier wieder raus?"
"Und wenn ja, mit welchen Schäden?"
Die Panikattacke war so heftig,
dass sie nicht mehr laufen
und sprechen konnte.
Erst im Spital kam sie zur Ruhe.
Eine Ruhe,
nach der sie sich gesehnt hatte.
Ich habe dort Blut geleckt
in dieser Ruhe.
Ja, das wollte ich.
Und für ihn ging das so nicht.
Ähm.
Dort gerieten wir auf Abwege,
glaube ich.
Ich habe mir dann gewünscht,
dass wir ein Refugium hätten.
Wie so ein Zimmer,
wo ...
... er oder ich - aber v.a. ich -
einen Rückzugsort hätten.
Ich brauchte Maura, mich selber,
ganz fest
und ...
... er ganz fest die Familie.
Und dann, ja ...
Nach zehn Ehejahren trennte sie sich
vom Vater ihrer Kinder
und zog
aus der Familienwohnung aus.
Das jüngste Kind war zwei Jahre alt.
Ihr Noch-Ehemann organisierte ihr
eine neue Wohnung,
nicht weit entfernt.
Die Kinder blieben bei ihm.
Mein Kissen
und noch zwei oder drei Dinge,
die er mir bereitgemacht hatte,
habe ich abgeholt.
Die Kinder hatten den Samichlaus
auf der Dachterrasse.
Es war mega traurig,
es war so etwas, das ich ...
Das ist ganz schwierig.
* Gedämpfte, sanfte Musik *
Ja, mhm.
Pfff.
Ja.
(Zittrige Stimme) Ich fuhr unten mit
dem Auto weg und hörte sie oben.
Ja.
* Melancholische Musik *
Ich bin nicht ganz gegangen.
Aber einfach topografisch.
Ha!
Ja.
Mhm.
Das war schlimm. Sehr.
Ja.
Sie sagt, sie habe in dieser Zeit
viel Alkohol getrunken.
Sie versuchte,
ihr Leben neu einzurichten
und sich von ihrer tiefen Erschöpfung
zu erholen.
Obwohl sie sich sicher war,
die richtige Entscheidung
getroffen zu haben,
haderte sie mit der Situation
und war traurig.
Als Liebespaar
hätten sie sich getrennt,
als Eltern seien sie immer
zusammengestanden.
In diesem Film vorkommen
möchte ihr Ex-Mann nicht.
Mit ihm
konnte ich gut darüber reden,
aber sonst haben sich die Leute
nicht mehr bei mir gemeldet.
Das Handy war stumm.
Wieso ist das so?
Oder wieso ...
Ich meine, das war sehr traurig -
da war ein Schulhausfest,
ich ging auch.
Da wurde "Hevenu Shalom Alechem"
gesungen.
Das war sehr, sehr traurig,
ich habe mega geweint.
Das war etwa zwei Wochen danach.
Natürlich war der ganze Clan da,
und auf der Strasse wurde einfach
die Strassenseite gewechselt.
Ich finde immer wieder erstaunlich,
wie viele negative Impulse kommen
und wie viele Leute es wagen,
Abwertungen auszusprechen.
Logisch wäre es als erstes wichtig,
zu fragen:
"Was brauchst du?"
"Wie geht es dir?"
"Wie können wir dich unterstützen?"
De facto ist es aber oft so,
dass die Bewertungen wie
"Wie kannst du nur?"
sogar umgemünzt werden
und man es auf sich bezieht.
Also: Eine Frau zieht aus,
sie gehört gar nicht
in mein Familien- oder Bezugssystem.
Das löst z.T. sogar Ängste aus
bei Aussenstehenden.
"Wie wäre das,
wenn meine Frau das machen würde?"
Vielleicht als Mann.
Oder vielleicht noch überraschender:
dass Frauen sagen:
"Wie kannst du das tun?"
Das gibt eine Verschärfung,
die Unterstützung fehlt komplett.
Aber eigentlich hat das viel mehr
mit der eigenen Geschichte zu tun
als mit derjenigen,
die gegangen ist.
Es ist ganz wichtig, die Empathie
und den Perspektivenwechsel
zu verstehen: "Wie ist es eigentlich
dazu gekommen?"
Die Gesellschaft greift da
ganz schnell zur Moralkeule.
Ich denke,
dass die Rollenanforderungen
nochmals höher geworden sind.
Man muss ganz viel erreichen.
Man wird nicht nur Mutter
und soll die perfekte Mutter sein,
sondern soll die anderen Rollen
noch behalten und leben.
Dann kommt noch
das Selbstoptimierende dazu -
da müsste man noch weiter ausholen,
aber das ist relevant.
Es ist nicht: "Mach es."
Sondern: "Mach es sehr gut."
"Geh zurück zum Job,
bleib dort erfolgreich."
"Schau, dass du deine Stelle
nicht verlierst."
"Bleib auch
eine attraktive Partnerin."
"Trag Sorge zu dir."
Und diese Wortwahl:
"Lass dich nicht gehen" oder so.
Das suggeriert, dass wir die
Perfektion auf so vielen Ebenen
anstreben müssen.
Ich finde es extrem auffällig,
wie diese Überforderung,
und all dem gerecht zu werden,
extrem schwierig ist.
Ich musste mich selber
und die Situation aushalten.
Ich musste die Reaktionen von aussen
aushalten.
Ich musste aushalten,
dass ich quasi schuld bin.
Ich war die Täterin,
war trotzdem traurig -
das war ein Verlust.
So eine lange Beziehung
geht auch an demjenigen,
der verlässt,
nicht spurlos vorbei.
Aber man hat die Erwartung.
Ich habe auch schon gehört:
"Aber du hast es ja verbockt."
"Tu jetzt nicht so."
"Was weinst du?" Solche Dinge.
Ich finde es sehr auffällig
wie vielleicht im letzten Jahrzehnt
der Fokus immer mehr aufs Kind und
dessen Bedürfnisse gelegt wurde,
und wie es gesund aufwachsen kann.
Das ist sehr wertvoll,
es ergibt auch Sinn,
dass Eltern sich überlegen,
wie ihre Kinder gesund aufwachsen.
Ich beobachte aber, dass der Fokus
oft so stark auf den Kindern liegt,
dass man gar nicht mehr schaut,
was man als Elternteil braucht,
um so gesund und stabil zu sein,
dass man dem Kind mitgeben kann,
was es braucht.
In unseren Workshops sage ich oft:
"Das Wichtigste ist eigentlich,
dass ich darauf achte,
dass ich stabil bin,
dass ich bei mir bin
und es mir gut geht."
Ich sage nicht, dass die Kinder
von alleine aufwachsen,
dass man nicht mehr viel
machen muss.
Aber wenn ich Ressourcen habe,
es mir gut geht, Energie da ist
und ich genug Selbstfürsorge habe,
ist es viel einfacher,
die Bedürfnisse der Kinder
zu spüren.
Ich kann mich stärker
auf sie einstellen.
Tatsächlich sagen Klienten oft,
dass es plötzlich
selbstverständlicher wird,
was sie brauchen.
Bei vielen oder fast allen Familien-
systemen, die jemand verlässt,
ist Selbstversorgung
ein riesiges Thema.
Es ist nicht mehr
im Gleichgewicht.
Darum soll man zuerst bei sich
selbst schauen, wo man steht.
Das ist essentiell für das
gesunde Aufwachsen der Kinder.
Das ist ähnlich wie die
Sauerstoffmasken im Flugzeug.
Die muss man auch zuerst
selber anziehen.
Es muss genug Energie da sein,
sonst kann ich nicht für die Kinder
und ihre Bedürfnisse da sein.
Mit ihrem Auszug ohne Kinder
hat Maura Stocker gegen ein
ungeschriebenes Gesetz verstossen:
Mütter müssen immer
bei ihren Kindern bleiben.
Und doch scheint es,
als hätte es sich gelohnt.
Ich weiss noch: Als ich
in der neuen Wohnung war, ...
... sagte eins meiner Kinder zu mir:
"Mami, du bist ja so lieb."
Ich glaube,
durch meine Entspanntheit,
dadurch, dass ich meine ...
meine ...
Meine Oberflächenspannung
konnte sich beruhigen.
Und dann war ich in der Zeit,
in der ich die Kinder hatte,
tiefenentspannt - mega!
Ich hatte wieder Ruhe,
wieder Platz auf meiner Haut
für Berührungen
und auch in meiner Seele,
weil ich wieder Zeit
für mich hatte.
Zeit zu lesen, ruhig sein,
weinen, andere Leute treffen.
Das hat schon sehr geholfen.
Die Batterie war wieder gefüllt.
Ich konnte wieder geben.
(Kind) "Du wirst dein Wunder
erreichen."
"Viel Spass, ich hab dich sehr fest
lieb. Küsschen aufs Nüsschen."
"Ich habe dich sehr fest gern. Pass
auf dich auf und geniess es. Kuss."
In diesem Haus wuchs Maura Stocker
mit zwei älteren Schwestern auf.
Wollen wir einfach
auf dem Sitzplatz sitzen?
Ja.
Ihre Eltern lebten
das klassische Familienmodell:
Die Mutter ist Hausfrau,
der Vater Forstingenieur.
Feuersalamander.
- Oh, jö! Mandaheiss.
Ja, es hat einen ganz jungen.
Ich nannte die früher Mandaheiss.
Ja.
(Mann) Wenn man hier anhebt, sieht
man Blindschleichen.- Nein, nein.
Schnecken.
- Schnecken hat es auch.- Wääh!
Willst du auch noch?
Warst du in deinen Augen
eine schlechte Mutter,
bevor du gegangen bist?
Ich glaube, ich habe das nie so ...
Nein, so nicht.
Ich wusste aber, dass ich so sehr
an meiner Grenze bin.
So.
Das habe ich auch physisch gemerkt.
Ich habe gemerkt ...
Wir haben oft solche Spiele gespielt
mit Wasser
und der Wasseroberflächenspannung.
Ich hatte das Gefühl:
"Ich halte, ich halte, ich halte."
Diese Oberflächenspannung ...
- Ein Tropfen, dann läuft es über.
Ein Tropfen. Und bevor es überlaufen
konnte, bin ich gegangen.
Es war so:
Ich halte, ich halte, ich halte.
Ich muss gehen,
damit nichts passiert.
Ich hatte einen kleinen Wutausbruch,
als sie es mir
am Telefon gesagt hat.
Ich war schaurig ...
Ich war wirklich sehr sauer.
Ich dachte: "Maura, das kannst du
nicht machen. Ihr habt drei Kinder."
"Versucht es einfach. Ihr habt
noch gar nichts ausprobiert."
Wir haben zehn Jahre ausprobiert.
Ja, aber nach der Entscheidung -
dass man vielleicht noch
etwas ausprobiert.
Das war ein heftiges Telefonat
von mir.
Oder, Maura, das hast du auch als
eine Art Zurechtweisung empfunden?
Vielleicht nicht Zurechtweisung ...
- Doch, eine Zurechtweisung.
Doch, das finde ich auch.
Aber das kam aus dem Bauch heraus.
Ich hatte das nicht unter Kontrolle.
Es hat einfach getobt.
Das war meine Reaktion.
Ich habe es dir zuerst erzählt.
Weisst du noch?
Mhm.
- Ja.
Du hast voll gechillt reagiert.
Weisst du das noch?
Wie habe ich reagiert?
- Gechillt, entspannt.
Du sagtest: "Ja, dann mach das."
- Ja.
Ja. Ich bin zwar ein impulsiver Typ.
Sagt man.
- Sagt man.
Aber solche Dinge
kann ich ziemlich gelassen nehmen.
Erstens war es ihre Entscheidung,
ihre Ehe.
Und zweitens, das kommt nicht
einfach so aus dem heiteren Himmel,
die Spannungen und Probleme
waren bekannt.
So gesehen ...
Nicht ...
Nicht, dass ich mich gefreut hätte,
überhaupt nicht.
Aber es war korrekt für mich.
Es war okay für mich.
Ich habe ja in meinem Leben
öfter Knall auf Fall
die Richtung geändert,
etwas anderes gemacht
oder bin aus etwas ausgestiegen.
Und im Nachhinein muss ich sagen:
Solche Weichenstellungen
sind in dem Moment hart,
können weh tun, aber ...
... sie haben auch etwas Gutes
eingeleitet.
Nur, wenn man irgendwo loslässt,
kann andernorts wieder etwas kommen.
Meine Reaktion
war anders als bei dir.
Es war eine Reaktion
aus dem Bauch heraus,
völlig unkontrolliert.
Das hat mich so tief getroffen.
Wieso denn?
Weil ich da ...
Ähm.
... vielleicht
noch etwas altmodisch bin.
"Man bleibt doch bei den Kindern."
Aber sie hat mich sofort korrigiert:
Sie verlasse ihre Kinder nicht.
Das war
eine ganz wichtige Ergänzung.
Denn ich sagte: "Du kannst doch
deine Kinder nicht verlassen."
Du sagtest mir dann:
"Ich verlasse meine Kinder nicht."
Das ist auch bis heute so.
Sie musste mir einfach erklären,
was genau ihr Schritt ist.
Es ist noch so ein Tabu.
Ich wurde so geschnitzt.
Ich musste sagen: "Das ist nicht so
schlimm." "Ich darf, man darf."
Man darf auch darüber reden.
Das war der Punkt,
an dem ich mich entschied
und das auch normalisieren wollte.
Es ist okay.
Man darf auch als Frau, als Mutter
gehen?
Absolut.
Darum bin ich auch hier
und zeige mein Gesicht.
Ich muss mich nicht kleinmachen,
schämen, verstecken.
Sondern mal darüber reden.
Es ist voll in Ordnung.
Ich wurde verschiedentlich gefragt,
ob das meine Tochter sei.
"Ja, das ist unsere Tochter."
Genau.
Aber eigentlich habt ihr
zu einem neuen Modell gefunden.
Ich muss sagen:
Ich habe das noch nie gehört.
Und die Diskussionen
mit verschiedenen Leuten
haben mir sehr viel gebracht.
Ich habe gemerkt,
dass man sogar darüber reden kann.
Meine Tochter hat ihre Familie ver-
lassen und man kann darüber reden,
dass die Frau die Familie verlässt.
Bisher war das tabu.
Männer dürfen das,
aber Frauen nicht.
Das war eine gute Bewegung für mich,
dass das raus geht,
dass die Gesellschaft sich
mit solchen Dingen
wirklich auseinandersetzt.
Es ist an der Zeit,
dass die Frau ihre Rechte
auch bewusster wahrnimmt
und keine Angst hat
vor solchen Entscheidungen.
Das schliesst nicht aus,
dass man es untereinander versucht,
und es möglichst gut macht.
Du sagtest einmal zu mir: "Er ist
der beste Vater, den es gibt."
Was will man mehr?
Er ist ein toller Mann,
ein toller Typ.
Und er ist den Kindern
ein guter Vater.
Und weil er so ein toller Typ ist,
liegt es auch wirklich drin,
dass die Kinder bei ihm sind.
Hat unsere Gesellschaft
ein falsches Bild
von der perfekten Mutter?
Unsere Gesellschaft hat zumindest
ein sehr strenges Bild
von der perfekten Mutter.
Ich würde gerne lernen,
das Wort "perfekt" wegzulassen.
Und auch lernen,
dass es Augenmass
und v.a. Flexibilität braucht.
Und auch den Perspektivenwechsel,
um zu sehen,
von man spricht - nicht jedes
Familiensystem ist gleich.
Mann soll wissen, dass es so viele
Modelle des Familienlebens gibt.
Es gibt nicht nur das eine.
Insofern zementieren unser System
und unser Bild der perfekten Mutter
die alten Rollen,
es engt extrem ein.
Auch Väter - das ist wichtig!
Je mehr der Fokus
auf der Mutter liegt,
desto mehr geht er vom Vater weg,
desto mehr
muss er ihn sich erkämpfen,
desto mehr muss das Paar
das umschichten,
als hätte man eine Wippschaukel.
Es wäre ja schön,
wenn man mehr von Anfang an
mehr Gleichgewicht anstreben würde.
Haben Mütter
einen grösseren Einfluss darauf,
dass es der Familie gut geht,
als Väter?
Ach, dieser Einfluss der Mütter ...
Da würde ich zuerst schauen,
wie es aufgeteilt ist.
Wenn eine Mutter praktisch zu 100 %
bei den Kindern ist
und der Vater fünf Tage die Woche
oder mehr weg ist,
dann sehen die Kinder natürlich die
stärkere Bezugsperson in der Mutter,
und haben z.T.
eine stärkere Bindung zu ihr.
Das muss aber nicht so sein.
Dann gibt die Abwesenheit der Mutter
einen grösseren Raum frei.
Wenn aber eine Partnerschaft -
wie das jetzt immer mehr kommt -
auf Augenhöhe und gleichberechtigt
gelebt wird,
nimmt dieser Einfluss -
was sehr positiv gemeint ist - ab
zugunsten eines Gleichgewichts
beider Elternteile.
Oder aller Elternteile.
Patchworkfamilien sehen nochmals
anders aus: noch mehr Elternteile.
Daher: Nein, die Mutter
ist nicht die Hauptverantwortliche
für das gesunde Gedeihen der Kinder.
Die Hauptverantwortung in der
Kindheit und Jugend von Lianna Müller
hatte nicht ihre Mutter,
sondern ihr Vater.
Die 28-jährige Bernerin
wuchs ohne Mutter auf.
Sie wohnt heute in einer Dreier-WG
in der Stadt Zürich.
Liana arbeitet hauptberuflich
als Fachfrau HR.
Daneben hat sie ein kleines Pensum
als Flight-Attendant bei der Swiss.
Sie macht sich bereit
für einen Flug nach Dubai.
Beim Reisen fühlt sie sich wohl.
Die Fähigkeit, sich schnell
an ihre Umgebung anzupassen,
zeigt sich auch in ihrem Dialekt.
Mit dem Vater spricht sie Bern-
deutsch, ansonsten Zürcher Dialekt.
Ich war schon als Kind
gern unterwegs.
Mein Vater sagt auch,
dass ich immer voll dabei war,
wenn man mich fragte,
ob ich bei Verwandten oder auswärts
übernachten wolle.
Ich bin gern zu Hause, aber das
ist für mich kein fixer Ort,
sondern dort,
wo ich mich wohl fühle.
Wenn das sich verändert,
verändert es sich halt.
Lianna Müller kam in Langental
im Kanton Bern zur Welt.
Sie hat einen
drei Jahre älteren Bruder.
Die Eltern hatten sich auf Hawaii
während eines Sprachaufenthalts
kennengelernt.
Als Lianna drei Jahre alt war,
ging ihre Mutter zurück in die Heimat
nach Malaysia.
Sie und ihr Bruder
blieben in der Schweiz beim Vater.
Ich kann mich gut
an meine Kindheit erinnern.
Er war ein extrem liebevoller Vater,
als ich ein Kind war.
Ich habe früher z.B. immer
bei ihm ferngesehen.
Ich war immer bei ihm auf dem Sofa.
Das ist eine der Erinnerungen.
Jeden Abend bevor wir ins Bett
gingen, durften wir etwas schauen.
Dann ging ich immer zu meinem Vater.
Dort bin ich immer -
v.a. wenn ich müde war - eingedöst,
so bei ihm und habe
auf seine Jacke gesabbert.
Lianna und ihr Bruder sahen
ihre Mutter nur während fünf Wochen
in den Sommerferien, als sie
zu ihr nach Malaysia flogen.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Bis ich fünf Jahre alt war,
holte unsere Mutter uns noch.
Nachher folgen wir als UM,
also alleinreisende Kinder,
nach Malaysia.
Ich glaube, meine Mutter wollte
vieles materiell zurückgeben.
D.h., ich fand es immer toll, weil
wir immer viel Spielzeug kriegten.
Ich habe das Gefühl ...
Malaysia hat mir immer gut gefallen.
Meine Mutter zeigte immer
auf meinen Bruder und sagte:
"Dieses Kind sieht aus
wie ein Asiat."
Und sie zeigte auf mich:
"Dieses Kind isst wie ein Asiat."
Daran habe ich
ziemlich gute Erinnerungen.
Liannas Bruder war sechs Jahre alt,
als die Mutter die Familie verliess.
Für ihn war es schwieriger.
Vorkommen im Film möchte er nicht.
In der Schweiz sah dann das Grosi
tagsüber zu den Kindern.
Liannas wichtigste Bezugsperson aber
war ihr Vater.
Es war wirklich mega strukturiert.
Es ist verrückt:
Auch 18 Jahre später
kann ich mich noch
an jeden Schritt des Tages erinnern,
weil er immer sehr strukturiert war.
Mein Vater weckte uns morgens,
immer um 6.30 Uhr.
Um 6.45 Uhr ist er los,
um mein Grosi zu holen
und dann war er meistens
spätestens um 7.15 wieder da.
In den 30 Min.
haben wir gefrühstückt,
uns angezogen, Zähne geputzt.
Über den Mittag
assen wir schnell zu Hause.
Am Abend wieder nach Hause.
Mein Vater kam nach Hause.
Dann brachte er sie nach Hause,
machte Hausaufgaben mit uns,
wir konnten noch fernsehen,
bevor wir ins Bett gingen.
Es war immer
die gleiche Reihenfolge:
Pyjama anziehen, Bettmümpfeli essen,
Zähne putzen, ins Bett.
Egal ob in der Schule,
in der KV-Lehre oder in diversen WGs,
Lianna ist immer die einzige,
die beim Vater aufgewachsen ist.
Sie ist eine Ausnahme.
(Frau) So viel. Ich glaube,
das ist alles Bärlauch.
Bärlauch, das sind
immer Einzelwüchse.
Müssen die Säcke voll sein
für unser Pesto?
Ja!
Ich würde gern einmal
etwas anderes experimentieren.
Für mich ist es halt
immer so ungewohnt,
weil ich sehr engen Kontakt
zu meiner Familie habe
und sie mir auch sehr wichtig ist.
Darum ist das für mich
immer so unnormal.
Es ist sehr schwierig,
sich in diese Lage zu versetzen
und sich das vorzustellen.
Für sie fände ich es schön,
wäre es z.T. anders oder leichter.
Ich wäre auch neugierig,
wie sie so wäre.
Ich habe sie nie gesehen.
Vater und Bruder kenne ich.
Lianna, erzählst du das jeweils
proaktiv oder wirst du gefragt?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Ich glaube,
aus meinem Umfeld wissen es alle,
also vom näheren. Aber sonst ...
Ich erzähle es, wenn es sich ergibt,
oder wenn ich etwas
von meiner Kindheit erzähle,
ist das meistens vom Vater.
Ich erwähne meine Mutter nicht so.
Das fällt auf. Einige Leute
fragen dann: "Und deine Mutter?"
Oder wenn jemand
nach meiner Herkunft fragt ...
Denn ich heisse ja Müller,
sehe aber nicht so müllerisch aus.
Dann wird gefragt:
"Hast du denn andere Wurzeln?"
Dann sage ich:
"Meine Mutter ist aus Malaysia."
Dann fragen sie automatisch: "Bist
du hier oder dort aufgewachsen?"
Dann fragen sie:
"Sprichst du Malay?"
Wenn ich verneine, fragen sie:
"Hat deine Mutter
es dir nicht beigebracht?"
So geht das immer.
Es kommt ab einem gewissen Punkt
im Gespräch automatisch.
Aber in der Regel eher, wenn man
mit jemandem näher zu tun hat.
Seit ihrer Kindheit
wird Lianna damit konfrontiert,
dass schlecht
über ihre Mutter gesprochen wird.
Es nervt sie.
Musstest du deine Mutter
anderen gegenüber verteidigen?
Absolut.
Wenn ich in meiner Kindheit
zu Freundinnen zum Spielen ging,
sagten sie:
"Ah, deine Mutter ist nicht da."
"Das könnte ich nie."
Ich finde es irgendwie auch ...
Ich finde es daneben,
denn inwiefern hat mir das
in dem Moment geholfen?
Ich hatte einfach das Gefühl,
die Mütter wollten nur sagen,
sie seien besser.
Die gängige Annahme, dass v.a. Mütter
zu ihren Kindern gehören, stört sie.
Bei einigen wenigen Dingen
hat eine Frau vielleicht
eine andere physische Voraussetzung
als ein Mann.
Aber bei der Kindererziehung
definitiv nicht.
D.h., mein Vater konnte mir
Vaterliebe geben,
die genauso wichtig ist
wie Mutterliebe.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Mit der Opferrolle,
die ihr häufig zugesprochen wird,
kann sie nichts anfangen.
Im Gegenteil, sie hat teilweise
sogar Verständnis für ihre Mutter.
Würdest du so weit gehen, zu sagen,
es ist völlig okay,
die Familie zu verlassen?
Ja.
Egal in welcher Situation?
Also ...
Nein, nicht in jeder Situation,
aber in unserer, ja.
Meine Mutter heiratete sehr jung.
Sie wurde sehr früh schwanger.
Sie stammt aus einer Kultur,
in der das das einzige Lebensziel
einer Frau ist.
Sie hat dann gemerkt, dass sie
auch andere Möglichkeiten hat,
und dass es ihr nicht so entspricht.
Und sie hatte keine gute Zeit
in der Schweiz.
Wir wuchsen sehr ländlich auf,
Rassismus war sicher ein Thema.
* Sanfte, klimpernde Klänge *
Wenn das Bleiben einen
so unglücklich macht,
dass es auch die Kinder beeinflusst,
oder sie es merken,
dann kann man gut in Erwägung
ziehen, ob es das Richtige ist.
Ich glaube, zu gehen, ist nicht
das Schlimmste, das man machen kann.
* Dumpfe, schwermütige Klänge *
Das ist Liannas Vater Walter Müller.
Er, der technische Kaufmann,
hätte nie gedacht,
dass er einmal alleinerziehend
sein würde.
Seit der Scheidung lebt er allein.
Also, jetzt ...
Was machen wir jetzt?
Jetzt müssen wir es ein bisschen
brennen lassen, damit es Wärme gibt.
Nachher müssen wir den Rost
irgendwo draufbringen.
Noch ein bisschen desinfizieren.
Er wurde lange nicht benutzt.
Am Anfang war es schon
ein seltsames Gefühl.
Das ist eine ganz neue Rolle,
mit der man sich nie befasst hat.
Ich zumindest nicht.
Ich kenne bis heute keinen einzigen
alleinerziehenden Vater.
Mütter viele, aber Väter
eigentlich nicht.
Wobei, wenn es so weit ist,
dann ...
... sieht man einfach die Situation
und das ist dann der Tagesablauf.
Und dann ...
Wenn man anfängt, zu überlegen,
dass man gerne ein bisschen
Zeit für sich haben würde -
das ist natürlich falsch,
das darf man nicht.
Aber in so einem Moment
geht es einzig um die Kinder.
Da muss man einfach die eigenen
Bedürfnisse hinten anstellen,
sonst funktioniert das nicht.
Der ganze Tag war eigentlich
sehr strukturiert.
Ich hatte das Gefühl - ich habe das
extrem geschätzt bei dir.
Wenn ich bei meiner Mutter war,
habe ich das sehr speziell gefunden,
weil sie nicht so organisiert ist.
Als Kind gab mir das
extrem viel Sicherheit.
Ich hatte meinen Rahmen.
Ich wusste immer:
Wenn ich irgendetwas habe,
dann bist du da.
Das ist auch bis heute so.
Es gibt fast keine Probleme,
bei denen ich denke,
dass ich sie nicht
mit dir besprechen kann.
Das rechne ich ihm extrem hoch an.
Denn er ist ja mein Vater.
Viele haben da
eine ziemliche Hemmschwelle,
z.B. ein Beziehungsproblem oder so
mit dem Vater zu diskutieren,
weil es der Vater ist.
Aber ich habe manchmal das Gefühl,
du bist z.T. im ersten Moment
überfordert,
weil ich immer noch
deine Tochter bin.
Und nachher switchst du so
und übernimmst dann
eine extrem objektive Haltung.
Und darum diskutiere ich auch gerne
Probleme mit dir aus.
Weisst du, was ich meine?
- Ja.
Ich denke schon,
dass es noch einfacher war,
als du noch klein warst.
Aber als sie dann
ein bisschen älter wurde ...
Ich weiss noch, als sie einmal von
der Schule nach Hause gekommen ist
und sagte: "Papi, die sagten,
ich sein angezogen wie ein Bauer."
Und sie war einfach
zweckmässig angezogen.
Mode ist halt nicht so meins.
* Hüpfende Klänge *
Von da an begann sie schon,
sich durchzusetzen.
Was eingekauft wird usw.
Aber nachher musst du
den Lead übernehmen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
wie lange die brauchen.
Wenn sie ganz schwarz sind ...
- Dann sind sie nicht mehr gut?
Als ich zum ersten Mal
meine Tage hatte ...
Da habe ich meine Tage bekommen
und ich war ziemlich ... Argh!
Man ist ja selber aus dem Häuschen.
V.a. weil ich früh dran war. Meine
Freundinnen hatten sie noch nicht.
Du sasst im Wohnzimmer,
ich lief zu dir
und sagte:
"Ich habe meine Tage bekommen."
Du sagtest:
"Soll ich dir etwas holen?"
Ich so: "Ja!" Und du: "Was?"
Und ich: "Weiss auch nicht!"
Du bist losgegangen und
hast diese dicken Boote gekauft,
die Linda-Dinger,
die du wahrscheinlich beim Grosi
mal gesehen hast.
Damit war ich
überhaupt nicht zufrieden.
Dann bin ich
zu den Nachbarn gegangen
und habe die Problematik
geschildert.
Dann hat sie mir
etwas von Always gegeben,
das Teenager normalerweise brauchen,
wenn sie zum ersten Mal
ihre Tage haben.
Dann bist du noch mal losgegangen
und hast die gekauft.
Ja.
Das ist schon etwas, das andere
vielleicht nicht so erlebt haben.
Aber ich finde irgendwie ...
Aber es geht ja auch.
Heute finde ich es ziemlich lustig,
damals dachte ich schon, ...
... es wäre schon cool gewesen,
eine Mutter fragen zu können,
die Ahnung hat
und nicht einen Vater.
Aber du hast eigentlich
recht gut reagiert.
Du warst sicher auch nervös.
Ja, es gibt schon solche Dinge,
die man irgendwann ausblendet
aus der Erinnerung.
Verdrängt.
So, jetzt ist es wieder sicher.
Hunger!
Ich nehme eine Ganze.
Doch, die ist ...
- Und die Verbrannte nehme ich noch.
Und wie läuft es so in Zürich?
Bei der Arbeit
habe ich genug zu tun.
Ja? Habt ihr viel zu tun?
- Mhm.
Wenn ich z.B. sage, dass ich
mit dem Vater aufgewachsen bin,
und erzähle, dass meine Mutter
nach Malaysia zurückgekehrt ist,
sagen sie: "Du Arme!"
Sie haben immer Mitleid
und eine negative Haltung
meiner Mutter gegenüber.
A la: "Sie ist eine Rabenmutter."
Das finde ich nicht fair,
weil es ganz viele Kinder gibt,
die ohne Vater aufwachsen.
Da frage ich mich,
wieso das gesellschaftlich
nicht so geächtet wird wie
bei der Mutter. Das ist unfair.
Ich will jetzt nicht sagen,
dass das ...
... nur positiv war.
Ich bin der Meinung, dass eine
intakte Familie mit zwei Eltern
für die Kinder das Beste ist.
Natürlich vorausgesetzt,
es funktioniert.
Das ist das Optimale.
Alleinerziehend ist einfach
die zweitbeste Lösung.
Ja.
- Aber ich denke schon,
dass ich euch nicht
so gut kennen würde,
wenn wir uns nicht getrennt hätten.
Dann wäre ich wahrscheinlich
beruflich mehr unterwegs gewesen,
als ich damals war.
Dann wäre ich wahrscheinlich
der typische Mann gewesen,
der einfach arbeitet.
* Idyllische Musik *
Ich gebe den Vätern da
ganz viel Eigenverantwortung.
Ich traue ihnen
auch wirklich viel zu.
Ich glaube, ein Vater
kann diese Rolle genauso einnehmen.
Er kann stabil da sein.
Was braucht ein Kind?
Stabile,
zuverlässige Bindungspersonen,
bei denen es weiss, dass sie kommen,
wenn sie sagen, sie kommen,
und sie müssen den Spielraum kennen.
Das ist überhaupt nicht
geschlechtergebunden.
Meiner Erfahrung nach können
oder müssen sich kleine Kinder
unter drei Jahren nicht
mit ihren kognitiven Erinnerungen
auseinandersetzen.
Das beginnt erst etwa
mit drei Jahren.
Da hat man Bilder oder Erinnerungen
an die Elterneile
oder Familienkonstellation.
Teilweise wird es als
eine gewisse Entlastung berichtet,
dass man sich nicht an das
vorherige Familienmodell erinnert.
D.h., so weit man sich erinnert,
war man immer alleine mit dem Vater.
Und der war halt immer da,
war stabil da.
Es gibt Kinder, die das integrieren
und damit ganz gut leben.
Wir sollten im Kopf behalten,
dass die Leute
unterschiedlich damit umgehen
und Kinder auch
krisenresistent sind.
Wir alle können mit Krisen umgehen.
Dann geht es darum,
wie das gehandhabt wird.
Lianna Müller hat ihre Mutter
vor sieben Jahren zuletzt gesehen.
Wir haben keinen Kontakt mehr.
Ich habe den Kontakt
vor sieben Jahren abgebrochen,
weil sie sehr ...
schwierig ist für mich.
Dadurch, dass sie sehr labil ist,
dass sie teilweise einfach
völlige Ausraster hat.
Sie hat das ganze Thema
nie richtig verarbeitet.
Darum habe ich mich entschieden,
dass ...
Mir ...
Es tut ... Es ist schlimmer
oder schwieriger,
mit ihr in Kontakt zu sein
als nicht.
Sie ist immer noch meine Mutter, ich
respektiere sie als meine Mutter,
aber ich habe entschieden, dass ich
sie nicht in meinem Leben will.
Maura Stocker hat ihr Leben
radikal verändert.
Sie hat aufgehört zu Rauchen
und Alkohol zu trinken.
Und sie geht
noch einen Schritt weiter.
Im Gegensatz zu mir hatten die
immer noch Alkohol drin,
oder kannten meine Vergangenheit.
Dann war es seltsam,
dass ich so gesund lebe,
bzw. einfach anders lebe.
Gesund sei jetzt mal dahingestellt.
Meine Haare tragen noch immer
die alte Vergangenheit mit sich.
Das braucht etwas Mut, gerade, wenn
man eine etwas grössere Nase hat.
Man sieht sich extrem
und muss mit all seinen Ecken
und Kanten Frieden schliessen.
Ich finde es super.
Und ...
Wenn ich denken will, oder ...
... eine Entscheidung treffen muss
oder so, merke ich:
Ah, sie sind noch irgendwie so ...
Dann gehe ich unter die Dusche
und schneide meine Haare.
Das ist sehr meditativ
und ich fühle es extrem.
Ich kann dann denken
und ja ...
* Beruhigende Klänge *
(Kind) "Liebes Mami,
ich liebe dich."
"Danke, dass du immer
für uns da bist."
"Dass du immer für uns kochst,
putzt, Wäsche machst
und uns beim Hausaufgaben machen
hilfst. Danke."
"Dein Mut ist eh das Grösste."
"Deine Frisur ist eh der Burner."
"Entschuldige, dass ich drei dei-
ner Kaugummis genommen habe, sorry."
"Danke, dass es dich gibt."
Maura Stocker hat
ihre persönliche Reissleine gezogen.
Sie ist ausgezogen,
wider allen Konventionen,
und doch ist sie Mutter geblieben.
Kinder bekommen zu haben,
hat sie nie bereut.
Es ist eine krasse Selbsterfahrung.
Die grösste Herausforderung
des Lebens und die schönste Arbeit.
Und gleichzeitig die krasseste,
die spannendste.
Ob ich es heute noch
so machen würde, sei dahingestellt.
Denn es ist müssig.
Aber ehrlich gesagt würde ich
diese Zeit nicht hergeben.
Lianna Müller,
die vermeintlich Verlassene,
fühlt sich alles andere als das
und möchte keinesfalls
in diese Schublade gesteckt werden.
Ich bin der Meinung,
dass Eltern es immer irgendwo
ein bisschen verkacken.
Und jedes Kind hat andere Ansprüche.
Es geht eigentlich gar nicht,
den Ansprüchen der Kinder
zu 100 % gerecht zu werden.
Ich kann von mir sagen,
dass das Aufwachsen mit meinem Vater
meine Ansprüche
sehr, sehr gut gedeckt hat.
Und auf die anderen, sagen wir,
20 % - oder 10 % -
kann ich auch verzichten.
Ich habe deswegen nicht das Gefühl,
ich hätte
eine schlechte Kindheit gehabt.
Tabus verschwinden nur,
wenn man sie bricht
darüber spricht
und dabei gehört wird.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Lisa Pfeiffer - 2022